diez años después del accidente nuclear
la central de fukushima están lejos de
ser reconstruida y lo peor es que a
causa de todas esas grietas cada día se
cuelan toneladas de agua de lluvia o de
las capas freáticas y se mezcla con el
agua que ya está en el interior de los
reactores para enfriarlos es una
pesadilla diaria para los ingenieros que
no dejan de seguir bombeando ese líquido
contaminado luego lo tratan y lo
almacenan en miles de cisternas la
central se ha convertido en una inmensa
estación de reservorios de agua más de
un millón de toneladas el lugar está
lleno
tratamos de disminuir la cantidad de
agua contaminada al principio recogemos
entre 400 y 500 toneladas al día ahora
son 100 o 150 toneladas si bien es
tratada este agua no está totalmente
limpia de sustancias radioactivas sigue
conteniendo tritio a pesar de eso japón
tomó la decisión de vaciar sus cisternas
en el océano pacifico en 2023 cuenta con
el apoyo del organismo internacional de
energía atómica
para el tritio la norma oficial
reconocida en nuestro país es menos de
60 mil bequerelios por litro incluso
aunque se tomen 2 litros de agua al día
con ese índice durante 70 años no hay
ningún riesgo para la salud pero la que
nosotros vertemos tendrá un índice que
será 40 veces menor de lo que dice esa
norma oficial así que será un proceso
muy seguro
pero los pescadores de fukushima temen
una nueva contaminación desde hace años
las pruebas que se realizan en cada
pesca demuestran que los peces están
sanos y sin embargo siguen teniendo una
mala imagen ningún país los quiere
comprar el proceso anunciado por las
autoridades podría poner en duda 10 años
de esfuerzos por asegurar a los clientes
al principio cuando me enteré de esa
decisión estaba muy impresionado pero
ahora lo que siento es rabia
si se termina por descubrir que los
niveles de radioactividad en el mar son
altos será una catástrofe para nosotros
porque el gobierno decidió poner
nuestras vidas en riesgo si ni siquiera
discutirlo con nosotros por esa razón el
precio de los pescados locales ya bajó
entre 20 y 30 por ciento
sin embargo la mayoría de los habitantes
que va a los mercados quiere seguir
siendo solidaria con los pescadores
locales siguen confiando en los
esfuerzos de las autoridades por evitar
una contaminación del océano
si no tomaron ninguna medida de
prevención sería preocupante están
haciendo pruebas en todos los pescados
así que eso da tranquilidad
[Música]
hemos tenido y yo sigo dándole productos
de fukushima a mi hija y ahora con mi
segundo hijo en el vientre haré lo mismo
en el mundo entero la industria nuclear
vierte al mar sus aguas cargadas de
tritio francia por ejemplo en particular
con la empresa de la vierte en el canal
de la mancha en un solo año diez veces
más tritio que el desecho anunciado en
fukushima
la ciencia dice que el desecho de tritio
no es tan peligroso pero solo es un
debate sobre la imagen es el típico
decir o fukushima da miedo es peligroso
no eso no es cierto pero las personas
utilizan eso sin fijarse en la ciencia
sin fijarse en las pruebas
corea del sur y china países vecinos en
malos términos con japón denuncian ese
desecho y en fukushima algunos
habitantes ya no confían en las
autoridades temen una contaminación
general de las aguas en el mar y en las
capas freáticas dos veces del año estas
12 madres cabeza de familia realizan
pruebas en el agua de mar recolectan 80
litros y luego los analizan en este
laboratorio creado poco después de la
catástrofe gracias a las donaciones del
mundo entero
[Música]
y los índices de radioactividad del agua
de mar hoy en día no son altos en cuanto
al agua del grifo justo después del
accidente el índice era alto pero ahora
ya no es así se estabilizó pero yo
personalmente todavía me preocupo y
entonces consumo agua mineral
arena de los parques agua de los ríos de
verduras estas madres realizan pruebas
cada mes en 200 productos que los
habitantes les llevan hicimos el
experimento con estos pimientos de
fukushima comprados en el supermercado
local
resultado su índice de radioactividad es
nulo son comestibles una buena noticia
para estos habitantes quienes no por eso
bajarán su guardia y mantendrán sus
controles
el problema de la radioactividad es que
afecta nuestra vida cotidiana la comida
los lugares donde vivimos los parques el
colegio desafortunadamente los niños no
pueden escoger lo que comen o dónde
viven
[Música]
así que nos toca a nosotros los padres
tener cuidado por eso ya hasta llegada
eran
si bien las regiones alrededor de la
central fueron descontaminadas por las
autoridades la amenaza de nuevas
contaminaciones radioactivas sigue
presente la central depende de esfuerzos
colosales que se llevan a cabo cada día
para evitar un nuevo accidente
diez años después del drama el corazón
de los reactores destruidos sigue
fundido